foreign
[Music]
basically every Mega Corporation is
subject to a mountain of criticism I
mean we can just walk down the list
Apple overpriced products Saudi aramco
pollution Microsoft OS Monopoly Google
got a collection Amazon underpaid
workers Berkshire Hathaway can't even
beat the market Tesla and Elon Musk fan
club United Health Group a massive wait
who even are these people they're worth
roughly 500 billion dollars but not many
even know about their existence even the
ones that are familiar with the United
Health Group only know them as an
insurance provider and I often don't
realize that they're literally the
eighth largest company in the world and
as we've discussed extensively on this
channel the companies that are most
dangerous are rarely the ones that are
front-facing like Google or Apple
usually the worst companies are the
background companies that no one ever
talks about like Johnson and Johnson and
a Nestle United Health Group it may seem
harmless at first glance as they simply
sell insurance something that's required
to get decent Healthcare in America but
if you take a closer look you'll see
that United Health is no exception to
the role as they have built their
fortune on the Bloods of tens of
millions of people in fact many would
even argue that United Health is the
route behind everything that's wrong
with the modern medical industry and
while this may seem like a bold claim
their actions honestly speak for
themselves I mean just think about this
there's only two ways that an insurance
company can make money maximize premiums
and minimize payouts maximizing premiums
itself could be argued to be unethical
when dealing with health but the real
evilness comes along with minimizing
payments to minimize payments insurance
companies work very hard to dissuade you
from having to cash in when this means
dissuading you from smoking or drinking
it that's a good thing but when this
means dissuading you from going to the
hospital or getting treatment well
that's a new low even for these
corporations so here's the truth behind
the half trillion dollar giant that no
one ever questions
one of the biggest problems with United
Health is that their business is
fundamentally flawed first of all have
you ever wondered why people don't just
pay for health insurance themselves we
pay for our own car insurance our own
home insurance our own life insurance
and any other type of insurance that we
decide to get except for health
insurance unless you're self-employed or
work as a contractor chances are your
employer pays for your health insurance
if you were to ask company owners they
will say something like we care about
our employees health and think that all
of them should have access to good
health care but that's a lot of BS in
reality companies offering health
insurance is a rather new invention and
it was by no means designed to take care
of employees the origins of company
sponsored health insurance can actually
be traced back to World War II at the
time the economy was booming thanks to
the war but inflation was also booming
so while companies were willing to
increase salaries to attract better
Talent the government did not want this
they feared that Rising wages would just
worsen the inflation problem so they
passed the 1942 stabilization act which
literally made it illegal for companies
to raise wages under normal
circumstances this would be a godsend
for employers but with so many young men
and women after War they were struggling
to find good workers so they started
offering benefits such as health
insurance very quickly
employers-sponsored healthcare plans
became the standard and while this
seemed like a good thing at the start it
didn't take long for employers and
health insurance providers to take
advantage of this you see it large
employers quickly figured out that this
was a great means of employee retention
they knew that smaller companies and
individuals could never Strike as good
deals with health insurance providers so
naturally larger employers would
generally always have the better health
insurance this strong legislated
employees from switching to smaller
companies or starting their own business
even if everything else made sense I
mean how many times have you heard about
people people staying at their crappy
corporate or government jobs because of
the health insurance according to Gallup
that's one in six U.S workers and that's
no accident it's by Design meanwhile
this was a massive win for health
insurance providers as well sure they
were giving big companies at massive
discounts but this significantly reduced
their workload they no longer had to
convince tens of millions of people to
purchase their plans instead they just
had to convince a few hundred companies
and that they would essentially have a
monopoly over the entire Market it also
helped that employers were generally
complacent customers their goal usually
wasn't to get a good deal or a fair
price they just cared about getting a
better price than smaller companies and
individuals and as long as that was the
case employers were happy which made it
easy for these insurance providers to
continuously jack up prices
foreign
provider's best interest that you cash
in as little of the benefits as possible
and over the decades they've gotten
extremely crafty with how they
accomplished this one of their go-to
methods isn't networks if you're not
from the US you're probably not familiar
with the networks but essentially what
it means is that just because you have
health insurance does it not mean that
you can go to any Hospital newer
legislation that has made this better by
basically making it illegal for
hospitals to straight up deny you health
care but it's still in your best
financial interest to go to hospitals
that are within your network this brings
up the question though when you or your
employer is paying tens of thousands of
dollars per year for health insurance
why in the world are you limited to
certain hospitals well the answer is so
that United Health Group can make more
money obviously it's cheaper to partner
with a select number of hospitals
instead of covering all hospitals but
there's more to this than just that by
partnering with the select number of
hospitals insurance providers are able
to get an even bigger discount on how
much they pay out here's the thing when
United Health Group exclusively partners
with someone like St David's Medical
Group Saint Davids is basically getting
a monopoly over all of United Health
group's customers this is obviously
extremely valuable and that's why Saint
Davids would be willing to give United
Health a massive discount but this is
not the only way in which United Health
saves money either by reducing the
number of supported hospitals insurance
providers are able to reduce the
frequency of hospital visits If people
could use the hospital right next door
they're obviously going to visit much
more frequently than if they had to
drive 10 miles to the closest hospital
in their Network something else that
health insurance providers leverage to
further dissuade hospital visits is
large deductibles if you're not familiar
with deductibles it's basically the
amount of money that you have to pay out
of pocket before any health insurance
kicks in the average deductible for
bronze plans is a whopping six thousand
nine hundred and twenty one dollars and
and it's not just lower income folks
that are opting for these low tier plans
either even people who can comfortably
afford the higher tier plans that often
choose the lower tier plans because
here's the thing would you rather pay
three thousand dollars per month and
have no deductible or pay one thousand
dollars per month and to pay seven
thousand dollars the one time you get
sick for most people who are relatively
healthy the answer is the second option
regardless of their financial situation
and when even people with money think
that your most comprehensive plans are a
rip-off there's clearly something really
wrong
foreign
so far most of the shortfalls that we've
discussed are applicable to the entire
health insurance industry and as the
largest health insurance provider in the
world United Health Group is by far the
worst offender for example do you know
when United Health Group had their most
profitable quarter ever it was actually
during the second quarter of 2020 when
the pandemic was at its absolute Peak
that quarter United Health Group
profited 6.6 billion dollars with just
doubled their usual profits at first
glance this might be a bit confusing but
when you think about it it makes sense
first of all all elective medical
procedures were paused during this time
period so United Health did not have to
pay out any of those on top of this even
people who needed medical attention were
wary of going to the hospital due to
fears of catching covid and lastly a lot
of people who didn't already have health
insurance got health insurance for
obvious reasons when you put all of this
together you end up with the most
lucrative Court order ever during the
worst Health crisis in modern history
yeah I don't think I have to explain why
that's so wrong on so many levels given
that they make all this money you would
hope that they at least pay out honestly
when the time comes but that's not the
case either United Health regularly
blackmails hospitals to pay their
doctors less for example near the
beginning of the pandemic United Health
terminated their contracts with
anesthesiology and the neonatal
practices in four states and the reason
for this was that the physicians at
these providers were making too much
money talk about the irony while United
Health refuses to be overcharged
themselves they're happy to overcharge
the government now this may come as a
surprise as a lot of people promote
Medicare as the solution but what you
don't realize is that a private
companies like United Health are
actually the ones that control Medicare
as well you see it back in the 1990s
Medicare was facing a 13 trillion dollar
funding Gap so Congress decided to
privatize a part of Medicare essentially
the government would simply foot the
bill and the private companies are the
ones that would actually take care of
all the insurance stuff I don't think
you'd be surprised to hear that these
companies use this opportunity to rip
off the government to the absolute Max
for example one of the strategies that
they used was over exaggerating client's
conditions this way the insurance
companies could charge the government
large premiums even though the client
was actually low risk according to a
whistleblower United Health was
regularly overcharging the government by
three thousand dollars and I think this
leaked email tells you everything you
need to know really go after the
potential risk scoring specifically
those with huge dollar opportunities
once this information surfaced the US
did go ahead and Sue United Health Group
and this will probably end in a ruling
that favors the us but if we're being
honest the us is going to find them like
5 or 10 billion dollars despite losing
tens of billions if not even over a
hundred billion dollars
foreign
after hearing things like this people
often Trend towards the idea of
Universal Health Care and maybe that is
the solution but the truth is that
that's unlikely to happen anytime soon
so the best thing we can do in the
meantime is try to take control of the
situation according to another
whistleblower the thing health insurance
companies fear most is a single pair of
Planet the reason if your single pair
plants so much is because it threatens
their Monopoly and control so maybe the
key is to Simply take ownership of our
health insurance just like we do with
every other type of insurance certain
companies that already allowed for this
Netflix for example offers company
provided insurance if you wanted but you
can also choose to refuse it and instead
take a 15 000 health insurance credit
that you can use anywhere you want if
more employees prefer this option I
suspect that more companies would start
offering this and this may just be what
we need to break the health insurance
Monopoly but that's just what I think
are you a fan of universal Healthcare
comment down below also drop a like if
you hope United Health group's Monopoly
crumbles to the ground and of course
consider checking out our Discord
Community such as future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more
questions are logically answered but
until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next one